ist das corona virus doch in einem
chinesischen labor gezüchtet worden
die debatte um diese frage eskalierten
und zwei wissenschaftler gehen in einer
bislang unveröffentlichten studie davon
aus dass ist durch sicherheitsmängel in
einem speziallabor zu der verbreitung
von saas kopf zwei gekommen ist sogar
der us geheimdienst ermittelt jetzt
klicks umsatz im future geht es dreimal
pro woche spannende science velos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
mehr als 3,4 millionen tote weltweit hat
die korona pandemie mittlerweile
gefordert und es wären viel mehr
geworden wenn nicht überall strenge
maßnahmen gegen das virus ergriffen
worden wären und so ist es verständlich
dass sich alle welt fragt wo der
ursprung dieser dramatischen pandemie
liegt ein großteil der wissenschafts
community ging bisher von der
sogenannten zu lose theorie aus demnach
könnte das virus auf zwei von einer
fledermaus über ein zwischen wird tier
auf den menschen übergegangen seien dort
bereits seit beginn der korona pandemie
gab es stimmen die sich gegen diese
theorie ausgesprochen hatten
immer wieder war davon die rede dass das
virus seinen ursprung möglicherweise
auch in einem labor in lausanne gehabt
haben könnte doch es gab keinerlei
beweise und auch keine indizien nur die
tatsache dass es in johann ein labor
gibt das mit corona virenforscher doch
jetzt gibt es gleich zwei hinweise die
auf das labor hindeuten zum einen
berichtet die britische boulevardzeitung
daily mail über eine bislang
unveröffentlichte studie die beiden
autoren der neuen studie sind selbst
wissenschaftler und wollen neue hinweise
darauf gefunden haben dass ist ein labor
unfall in der chinesischen stadt wuchern
gegeben hat demnach kam es dadurch zu
der weltweiten pandemie mit den
zahlreichen toten konkret weisen die
beiden autoren auf die so genannte gen
auf function forschung hin hierbei
werden viren künstlich verändert um sie
so beispielsweise ansteckender zu machen
so kann untersucht werden welche
potenziellen auswirkungen die
veränderten viren auf den menschlichen
organismus haben
in der aktuellen studie ist die rede von
zitat einzigartigen fingerabdrücken in
dem virus und genau das lässt ihrer
meinung nach
einzig und alleine eine manipulation im
labor als ursprung des virus und was
noch auf das virus hin deutet laut dem
us geheimdienst waren ende november 3
forschende des viren labors in wo haben
so schwer erkrankt dass sie ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert werden mussten
was steckt dahinter und was sagen andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dazu woher stammt das virus wirklich
alle antworten auf diese spannenden
fragen gibt es in diesem video
bisher ging man davon aus dass saas kopf
zwei zu den sogenannten psychosen gehört
gemeint sind damit viren die aus dem
tierreich auf uns menschen überspringen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
hatte im märz dieses jahres 2021 einen
ersten bericht dazu vorgelegt die
fachleute hatten es hier als zitat
extrem unwahrscheinlich eingestuft dass
das corona virus in einem labor
entstanden ist stattdessen hatte man
hier die 2000 theorie im visier demnach
sei es zitat wahrscheinlich bis sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das virus saß kopf
zwei von einer fledermaus über einen
zwischen wird auf den menschen
übergegangen ist so wurde in dem bericht
ein großer markt den buchern kartiert
dabei wurde klar dass die meisten
nachgewiesenen saß kauf zwei proben in
der nähe von marktständen aufgetaucht
sind an denen tiere verkauft worden
doch klar ist bis heute ist unklar
welches tier als zwischenwirt fungiert
haben könnte das den erreger dann
letztendlich an uns menschen
weitergegeben hatte eine spur
dass das virus durch einen laborunfall
entwichen sein könnte hatten die whu
fachleute demnach nicht gefunden und
deshalb auch nicht weiter verfolgt für
die wissenschaft war damals klar ohne
hinweise ohne verdachtsmomente konnte
man diese these nicht belegen sie war
also deshalb extrem unwahrscheinlich
schließlich konnte dies auch bei anderen
neu auftretenden infektionskrankheiten
beobachtet werden ebola hiv und ziegler
beispielsweise nahmen ebenfalls nach
einem sogenannten spill over aus der
natur ihren anfang so genannte hufeisen
fledermäuse könnten der ursprung eines
lars koch zwei ähnlichen virus sein
das legen genom untersuchung nahmen es
sprach also einiges für die these der
zuse doch für diesen bericht gibt es
mittlerweile kritik mitte mai hatten
knapp 20 wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler einen beitrag in dem
renommierten fachmagazin
die in science veröffentlicht und darin
gefordert diese sogenannte public hippo
these genauer zu untersuchen sprich sie
bemängeln dass die labor ursprungs these
gar nicht wissenschaftlich
ausgeschlossen worden war das war
wahrscheinlich nämlich auch gar nicht
möglich skepsis äußerten auch die
regierungs vertreterinnen und vertreter
einiger staaten und eben auch die
besorgnis dass die whu fachleute gar
nicht den zugang zu wichtigen daten in
china hatten fest steht die debatte um
den ursprung des neuen krone virus ist
heftig denn sie ist nicht nur
wissenschaftlich sondern auch politisch
und das gerade zum zeitpunkt von
gesprächen zwischen staats und
regierungschefs aus china und den usa
hinzu kommt jetzt eben diese bislang
unveröffentlichte studie eines
internationalen forschungsteams über die
die britische boulevardzeitung daily
mail berichtet der britische
wissenschaftler englisch belgrad und der
norweger bürger hören sind gehen demnach
von sicherheitsmängeln in einem
speziallabor in hanaus durch die
sogenannte gaynor function forschung sei
es letztendlich zu der verbreitung von
saas kopf freibekommt zu die these
hier werden viren im labor künstlich
verändert so soll analysiert werden
welchen einfluss solche manipulationen
auf die infektionswege haben können eine
umstrittene sache auch in der
wissenschafts community selbst denn zum
einen kann solch eine forschung dazu
beitragen viren zu verstehen und so auch
mögliche weitere pandemien bereits im
vorfeld zu verhindern oder sogar zu
stoppen auf der anderen seite sind die
risiken natürlich groß und die gefahr
besteht dass so pandemien ausgelöst
werden in der bislang unveröffentlichten
studie sprechen die beiden forscher laut
daily mail von zitat einzigartigen
fingerabdrücke in dem virus darauf waren
sie bei der analyse von stichproben
gekommen die sie durchgeführt hatten um
einen möglichen impfstoff zu entwickeln
diese fingerabdrücke sind ihrer ansicht
nach eindrückliche hinweise auf eine
manipulation im labor konkret geht es um
eine verdächtige reihe von insgesamt
vier aminosäuren die ihrer ansicht nach
in der natur in einer reihe von
höchstens drei aminosäuren vorkommen
diese viererreihe ist demnach zitat
extrem unwahrscheinlich der verdacht der
beiden wissenschaftler hat es in sich
sie gehen davon aus dass die
chinesischen kolleginnen und kollegen
das natürliche corona virus aus
chinesischen höhlen fledermäusen nahmen
um diesem dann ein neues bike protein
hinzuzufügen eine absichtliche labor
manipulation also doch das autorenteam
geht noch weiter er wird chinesische
forschende hätten nach dem ausbruch der
korona pandemie versucht spuren zu
verwischen virus versionen seien
manipuliert worden um vorzutäuschen dass
das virus auf natürliche art und weise
entstanden sei so hätte man ablenken
wollen von der zitat vorsätzlichen
zerstörung verheimlichung oder
verunreinigung von daten die britische
daily mail zitiert das autorenteam
folgendermaßen es scheint dass das
erhaltene virus material und die
dazugehörigen informationen zerstört
worden sind daher sind wir mit großem
datenlücken konfrontiert die vielleicht
nie gefüllt werden
der appell der beiden forscher die
sogenannten game of function experimente
müssten grundlegend neu bewertet und
überdacht werden eine
grundsatzentscheidung sei notwendig um
zu klären ob derartige forschung
weiterhin zu vertreten ist die beiden
forscher hatten ihre ergebnisse bereits
vor einem jahr veröffentlichen wollen
doch damals hatten sie keine
fachzeitschrift gefunden diese davon
überzeugen konnten bereits damals gab es
kritik an ihren ergebnissen beide
wissenschaftler werden nämlich mit einer
pharmafirma in verbindung gebracht die
an einem corona virus vakzine also einem
impfstoff arbeitet wollen del gleich und
wirr sind mit ihrer analyse
hauptsächlich ihre geschäftlichen
interessen pushen und möglicherweise
sogar werbung für ihren impfstoff machen
sobald die studie der beiden offiziell
veröffentlicht ist wird die
wissenschafts community sicherlich
erneut stellung beziehen und die
ergebnisse bewerten mittlerweile
ermitteln aber auch die us geheimdienste
und us präsident joe biden erwartet die
ergebnisse dazu innerhalb von 90 tagen
er erwartet dass die geheimdienste
weitere infos sammeln und analysieren
die uns zitat einer endgültigen
schlussfolgerungen näher bringen könnten
in einem ersten bericht zum ursprung der
pandemie fehlt beides aussage zufolge
noch an informationen um das szenario
abschließend zu bewerten und jetzt
kommen die drei erkrankten aus dem labor
die im virus labor in hand arbeiteten
und im november 2009 10 stationär
behandelt werden mussten
so genau zu dem zeitpunkt als die
pandemie wohl begann sich auszubreiten
die symptome sollen den von kogit 19
oder ähnlichen krankheiten entsprochen
haben die chinesische regierung
widerspricht entsprechenden berichten
war es nun also der menschliche kontakt
mit einem infizierten tier oder doch
etwa ein laborunfall dass die
öffentlichkeit antworten auf diese
fragen haben möchte ist verständlich
denn dann könnte man präventiv handeln
um weitere mögliche pannen in zukunft zu
vermeiden übrigens nicht nur hinblick
auf einen laborunfall denn eigentlich
steht ja bereits jetzt fest das virus
ist so oder so menschen gemacht denn wir
menschen dringen massiv in unberührte
wildnis vor und der kontakt zwischen
wildtieren und menschen wird immer enger
wir jagen wilde tiere und handeln zum
teil illegal mit ihnen außerdem
zerstören wir den lebensraum diverse
arten wir sind ausserdem verursacher
einer katastrophal rücksichtslosen
massentierhaltung und genau das sind die
zutaten die die entstehung neuer
krankheiten begünstigen so oder so die
diskussion um den startpunkt der
pandemie ist wichtig aber mindestens
genauso wichtig ist die debatte darüber
was alles schiefgelaufen ist nachdem das
virus sich seinen weg durch die welt
warte vor allem geht es jetzt darum die
spannungen zwischen den usa und china
nicht noch größer werden zu lassen denn
in aktuellen gesprächen geht es gerade
um die eindämmung der pandemie und das
verhalten bei zukünftigen notfällen
ich habe corona überlebt was mir zu
denken gibt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
hier unter dem video ist der button
einfach draufklicken ist schließlich
kostenlos wir bleiben dran am thema und
vergesst nicht auch den podcast zu
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran